look that's really helped you on
screenwriting it's not really a specific
screenwriting book it's the war of art
by Steven Pressfield yeah the war
gardens by Steven Pressfield it's it's a
book it's not a book on screenwriting
it's a book on getting things done and a
lot I think I don't know one of his
books is called do the work so I mean
his main gist of of every of the book is
do the work as in sit down and
physically do the work and then the rest
of the book kind of talks about fears
and how to get past that but through the
lens of if you just do the work your
fears will go away norley shrink um
which is true i mean you know doing
something builds confidence and
confidence builds a built ambition that
makes sense so that's pretty much the
gist of the of this book which is a
great read it's definitely if you're in
any kind of creative field and if you're
stuck even if you're not stuck and if
you're just starting out it's definitely
it would probably be more beneficial to
you than the standard screenwriting
screen book that's gonna tell you how to
do screenwriting but not really tell you
how to be creative which is like a big
thing you know there's all these books
and stuff fun on how to how to manually
do screenwriting how to do break down a
movie into the three-act structure how
do you write a three-act structure movie
how do you do the hero's journey and
there's there's very little on how you
physically do it there's very little
something this is obviously very
personal opinion the two most important
parts of filmmaking our creativity and
originality and there's very little
books on that there's you know there's
kind of books in the art vein of how you
be original but there's very little and
filmmaking on that and that's what we
admire in filmmaking it's it's you know
there's great movies that are 3x
structure although movies that nobody
really likes and then there's there's
things you know that like beasts of the
southern why
something that's very original that you
know that's what people respond to so
it's kind of odd that there's so many
books on this one subject and so little
on something that matters so much to me
it's a personal opinion about filmmaking
you